hello everyone and welcome back to the
chess 24 legends of chess tournament we
are in round seven and it's uh
game four of the match magnus carlsen vs
peter swiddler it was uh three games uh
filled with uh with uh some real
excitement
uh magnus had uh had his chances uh in
game two
and well basically it was a pretty
equalish match but magnus really had
some uh great winning chances in uh in
game two not just winning chances the
position was winning
but it's a rapid game no no one can see
everything and this is now game four the
previous
three games have been drawn uh and
whoever wins wins the match or rather if
it's a draw they go into armageddon so
magnus with the white pieces opens with
d4 with knight to f6 by swiddler knight
f3
uh and the g6 we have bishop to f4 uh
magnus goes for his uh famous london
system uh with bishop to g7 by swiddler
and e3 and civil largest castle is very
uh a natural development with bishop to
e2 by magnus and
c5 now striking in the center castles by
magnus
and queen to b6 now putting pressure on
the b2 pawn as one usually does
when playing against this system and the
most common move here is knight b to d2
but magnus goes for queen to c1
uh sorry uh first knight beat to d2
uh give trying to give up the b2 pawn
and although it
may be possible to capture it no one
ever captured this pawn like
ever uh in you know top top tier
tournaments uh because knight c4 then
attacks the queen
and it's uh well uh white will get just
a lot of development for for the
sacrifice pawn
and if you're not sure about this which
i'm pretty sure no one is there's no one
ever captured this
you just don't do so instead filler goes
for d5 it is the most uh
common move here and only now queen to
c1 magnus defends now the b2 pawn and
here there is one game in the database
where c captures and d4 was played
but swiddler continues with knight to c6
and it is as a movie that we have a
completely new game
uh so here magnus continues with c3 i
just
strengthen his center uh and svidler
goes after the strong dark square bishop
so tonight the
h5 attacks the bishop also opens up this
bishop's diagonal
bishop to g5 by magnus magnus trying to
create some weaknesses on the king side
by getting peter to
advance his pawns which is exactly what
he does so h6 bishop h4 and now g5 and
here
was the first uh actual think of the
game that
magnus took a little bit longer uh he he
was designing
probably between ideas like just uh
knight characters here as it opens up
the attack uh towards this knight
although it is very unclear for example
something like this you grab two points
for a piece you have an attack on the
knight
uh and well could be maybe playable but
uh the the engine doesn't like it and
neither does magnus another
thing you could do is before just
retreating is something like a captures
here
attacks the queen and after queen
captures now 91. now offer a a trade of
pieces here uh bishop for a knight but
black would be very happy here
first a remaneuver with an attack on the
queen queen b6 and now you grab it back
but black is the one who has the bishop
pair uh black has a
very nice queen a very nice central
control e5 is coming and
once you move the king let's say to h8
it will be very safe there
y doesn't have a dark square bishop and
also you can just shift the rook over to
the g
file so it would be black would enjoy
this position so instead after g5 magnus
just goes back
although he probably did check all of
these lines and now spidler just trades
it we have knight captures and
h captures and with this uh switzerland
wins the bishop pair
uh and strikes uh in the center with e5
and if you saw this position like in a
book written
i don't know uh maybe 20 years ago the
author would be like
uh black just equalized with this e5
more or maybe uh black can never be
worse or something like that but uh
uh it is definitely the the principle
the way to go
uh just striking in the center so knight
captures on e5
knight captures and d characters on e5
we have bishop captures on e5
and now a very interesting maneuver by
magnus he goes for e4
uh and e4 is very interesting because
after d captures any for what was played
magnus doesn't recapture it by knight
captures but rather goes
knight to c4 with an attack on the
bishop and the queen
uh queen moves to defend the bishop so
queen e6 and now comes queen e3
attacking this pawn and this pawn and
this ha this is how magnus wins his pawn
back
by uh gaining more activity so bishop
back to g7 of course zwiddler doesn't
want to give up his strong dark square
bishop especially now that he created
some
uh weakness to zero around his king and
now queen captures on c5 magnus wins
back his pawn
but just b6 preparing to develop this
light square bishop let's say to this
diagonal bring the rook into the game
and so on
so queen to a3 by magnus and it is a
it is kind of a weird uh square for the
queen
it's hard to say where the queen will go
from there and
this is probably what uh convinced peter
that he should now strike
in the king side and he does with this
f5 move and now
uh well he's of course preparing f4
maybe maybe f3 e3
and so on and carlson's queen is for the
moment pretty much out of the game
and you don't have any like 93 ideas
with this
it seems uh like there could be
something but you either just move the
king or bring the queen here prepare
bishop e6
uh and so on so here after f5 magnus
goes rook
a to b1 he does have excellent control
of the e6 square so
even if he wanted he can just play queen
here but even better would be maybe just
bring the rook over here
so here uh sliddler goes bishop to b7
uh and then now comes rook to d6 so uh
gaining a lot of activity for this rook
there's no way to stop this so
slither doesn't even try to prevent this
rook from reaching this
we have queen back to e8 and now uh a
lot of moves are possible here uh for
example knights the e3 preparing to
shift the bishop over to this diagonal
might be a very nice idea
uh but magnus goes for a very
straightforward bishop to h5 now just
attacks the queen here
and he wants to trade this uh this
bishop for this bishop but you don't
just trade bishops you also allow this
rook this
beautiful active square so instead a
swiddler just goes back
queen is seven and now uh magnus again
took some time to think here he played
knight the e3 now
there was the the extremely interesting
knight the e5 with a double attack on
the bishop here
uh hoping for bishop captures on e5 and
then you get this discovery here just
the rook g6
check and the queen falls or you defend
the uh the queen with the king but now
just uh pretty much anything wins
as the king is now in front of the
bishop so you can fool around here
let's say king g7 you go back check you
go back here now you can pick up the b6
pawn
at least grab some pawns before you grab
the queen king g8
and now you grab the queen but after
let's say this you capture here and of
course
white is completely winning here so
after this queen a7 move although very
interesting 95
magnus decides for knight to e3 rather
and now comes bishop back the e6 now he
wants to play bishop to f7
and well trade off this uh this light
square bishop so magnus goes back bishop
to b1
now with the very interesting threat of
uh rook captures on e6
if queen captures then just bishop b3
just wins the queen as the queen would
be on the same diagonal as the king
and the situation on the clock is 10
minutes magnus uh with uh
six minutes for peter so peter
continues pushing on the king side with
f4 he's not
worried about this as he will also win
uh win a piece here so it's not now it's
not a problem
uh and magnus after taking some time to
consider the resulting end game decides
to
enter the end game so rook captures on
e6 now of course you cannot capture
because of the
the idea that we've just mentioned uh
and uh
queen captures an a3 we have b captures
on a3
and now f captures an e3 uh swiddler
wins back his piece
f captures an e3 and now rook captures
on f1 so everything gets traded off
king captures and king to f8 and now we
have this resulting end game
where magnus is up upon but he has a
double
double g pawn and a double a pawn and
his bishops of opposite color so all in
all
uh looks like uh looks like a a very
drawish position but of course it's uh
carlson's last game with white of course
he will try everything uh before uh well
before going to armageddon so he starts
bringing the king into the game king e2
and rook the c8 by zwiddler going after
the c3 pawn we have bishop to b3 now
uh offering the the c3 pawn there's no
real good way to defend it as it was
attacked twice so rook captures and now
rook captures an e4
uh we have rook to c5 by switzerland and
now switzerland is saying okay i control
the c5 square with my pawn i control the
e5 square with my bishop
i'm just going to shift this rook from
here to here and that
that's my plan for this game easy draw
and we go into armageddon
and in fact uh this uh this seems to be
true so magnus goes to rook to e6 and
now
rook to e5 fiddler offers a trade of
rooks as of course the
uh the opposite color bishop end game is
a draw
uh so rook back to d6 by magnus and now
uh
king to e7 attacking the rook magnus
tries to attack the bishop's filler goes
back and now
g4 and okay we'll go back to c5 as we
are sticking to his plan
and we have a4 by magnus we have rook to
e5
and now king to d3 uh we have rook back
to c5 by swiddler
just repeating e5 c5 and bishop to c for
now so rook to e5 and now comes
rook to c6 here magnus tries to take
away the c5 square from the rook
uh but a swiddler just uh goes back so
again offering a trade of rooks we have
rooked the d6 by magnus
and now king to e7 attacking the rook we
have rook to g6 now and king back to f8
so it seems that there is no way to make
a breakthrough here
but there are some more pawn push pushes
to be made so magnus goes for e4
and now uh we have rook to c7
uh uh by svidler now not repeating rook
to e5 uh probably
probably uh to to avoid something like
bishop to d5 which would
then take away the the c5 square from
the rook so
instead he goes rook to c7 so he doesn't
uh
get locked out with the bishop and now
comes a5 by magnus now with the rook
away from the fifth rank magnus creates
some weaknesses here
so svetler captures we have captures
here and now rook to
a6 going after the a5 pawn we have king
e7
and now uh here uh comes a very very
interesting move it's the only way to
look for any advantage in this position
as white and even feel free to pause the
video here to try to find this move
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting that
the pawn can now finally cross the e5
square
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's e5
and the reason why e5 is so strong
because if it's captured rookie 6 check
wins the bishop so
uh magnus was able to create some poison
in the position so spiller went back
king to f8 uh and now comes rook
captures on a5
grabbing that pawn and okay now magnus
has a has a nice pass the
past pawn defended by the rook uh the
pawn is coming to e6 which is defended
by the bishop and
things are well things are definitely
improving as white is making some
progress so king back to e7 by swiller
and now bishop back to b3 so the king
can now come into the game
as the bishop was vulnerable on c4 so
rugby seven uh and now uh king to e4
grabbing more space with bishop to f8
it's very hard to move for silver's king
as the bishop and pawn are really
controlling the squares here so he goes
bishop to f8 but now
king f5 we rook to c7 and
now comes rook to a6 grabbing more more
squares
uh we have king to e8 and now king to g6
by magnus
we rook to b7 now just uh waiting to see
what magnus will do and do not
rook the e6 with check we have king to
d8
and now rook to f6 now the bishop is
under attack so bishop to e7
and now a very sneaky move by magnus now
he says okay you can have the rook just
king captures on h6 and now the point is
if swiddler grabs the rook then yes pawn
captures and let's say
whatever as you kind of do need to bring
the king over here then you can just
pick up this pawn
you're up three pawns and when this
spawns
pawn starts marching forward along with
the f pawn it's game over
so swiddler has to go uh do something
else we have rook to b5 now or going
after the pawn
but now comes rook to f5 now just
defending the pawn
uh we've broke the b4 going after the g4
pawn
and now e6 by magnus now allowing this
capture so he can
start making more progress so spidler
captures it there is no
better move to be made and now rook to
d5 with
check king to e8 and now king to g6
now a lot of squares are taken away from
the from the
from the black king the pawn really
constricting the the movement of the
king
so rook to f4 uh but now comes rook to
a5
now going after this uh pawn here
there's no way to prevent this
king to f8 was played and now rook
captures on a7
and here rook the f6 with check we have
king to h7
and now you have to be careful otherwise
rook to a8 just wins the game the
black king has no squares you're you're
gonna have to give up the bishop and
it's just gonna be a very quick death uh
uh from then on
so bishop back to d6 but now comes a
rook to f7 a probably the the quickest
way to end
uh rook to f7 check forces the rook
trade where rook captures pawn captures
and it was uh in this position that uh
peter swiddler resigned the game on move
on move 64 as allman should as there is
nothing more to be done here now white
white is up two pawns and there there's
just no playing this it's the
simplest principle of two weaknesses you
have this guy here that's a weakness and
even though maybe you can defend this
guy uh
then this pawn creates a second weakness
and you will not be able to take care of
everything
uh at some point the bishop will have to
move you're either going to win this
pawn and then push this pawn
uh it's just not possible to hold this
which of course
they both know and uh here swiller
resigns
so really a wild wild match i really
thought it could go
uh either way especially this game four
i really thought that now okay magnus
had his
great chance in game two and uh fiddler
defended well he defended well in game
one
and now in game four he started that
attack with a nice going f4
you know just uh going after carlson's
king carlson had a somewhat of an
inactive queen on a3
but it's only only uh you know visibly
inactive
uh like the queen was doing so much from
a3 actually
but yeah i thought it would go uh
peter's way but it didn't magnets wins
another game
uh without reaching armageddon so for
now only vasily manchuk
got magnus starmageddon uh other than
that magnus gets the full three points
on all other matches
so uh he is the the leader uh still but
we are going to discuss
the standings as we are going to show
some more games from this round there
were
quite quite a lot of good ones so yeah
once again i do hope you enjoyed it i
would like to thank
riyans renzburg
kumar koshti uh kai einer uh tour force
uh david weiner
weinrob and mark poitras for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
uh continuing the coverage of the chest
wonderful legends of chester
and checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day